objectif autonomie le comité des
yvelines de l'association valentin à lui
a convié différents acteurs pour par les
technologies et évolution de la médecine
autour de la déficience visuelle
c'est très important pour nos amis
déficients visuels de voir les premiers
projets parce qu'il ya un certain nombre
de produits qu'on leur a présenté
aujourd'hui qui sont au stade de projet
ou de prototypes et les développements
de la médecine qui sont pour eux des
facteurs d'espoir extraordinaire quand
le professeur loger leur explique qu'on
va pouvoir greffer des cornées donc on
va pouvoir arriver à l'oeil artificiel
pour des gens qui voit plus du tout
c'est un espoir colossal donc c'est des
journées très important de coureurs
parmi les objets présentés le panda
guide un casque de réalité augmentée qui
filme l'environnement et décrit les
objets autour de la personne et une
canne connectés nous mes chers parents
qu'est ce que c'est cher pas finalement
bas c'est ce qu'on appelle un assistant
intelligent
pourquoi pas ce qu'il va apporter des
informations lors des déplacements que
les personnes déficientes visuelles ne
pourrait pas avoir tout seul ou
difficilement à l'aide d'une oreillette
sans fil et d'un système gps l'appareil
guide l'utilisateur de la direction à
prendre autant d'attentes pour son
prochain bus ya vous dire arrêtez être
dirigeant temps et vous allez entendre
habib sy voulait pasta rêve fait rien il
va dire automatiquement le deuxième
arrêt tout seul un dispositif déjà
utilisé par plusieurs dizaines de
personnes en france et qui a un coût 700
euros sont à débourser pour une canne
connecter pour les mal et non voyants la
technologie n'est pas la seule réponse à
avoir à leur demande d'autonomie
mais côté accessibilité dans les gars
dans les musées dans la rue dans tout ce
que vous
et la civilité en france et on est en
retard beaucoup chaud